- [Interviewer] Cynthia.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Cynthia,
where you from originally?
- Santa Barbara.
- [Interviewer] Santa Barbara.
And how long have you been
down here in Skid Row?
- [Cynthia] Seven years.
- [Interviewer] Seven years.
And what is your drug of choice?
- [Cynthia] Heroin.
- [Interviewer] Heroin?
What age did you first get into drugs?
- Oh, I started probably
when I was 13 with weed
and then and then coke, PCP
and then it just escalated
when I turned 20, I tried
heroin once, I didn't like it,
believe it or not.
And I left Santa Barbara,
I moved back to L.A.,
to go stay with my mom for three years
and then went back to Santa Barbara
and all my friends were using.
So I just, it's been my whole
life and it's just terrible.
It's a blink of an eye.
- [Interviewer] You ever overdose?
- Oh God, yeah.
Many times.
- [Interviewer] What's that like?
- I think you don't know
cause you don't remember none of it.
There's several times
I've got up off the ground
and looking for my shit and they're like
"bitch, don't you know you just OD'd?"
You don't really remember it.
- [Interviewer] You're just out.
- You're just gone, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And have
you ever been clean?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I managed a sober
living home in Santa Barbara
called Woodridge, I worked at the airport,
I had two full-time jobs and I relapsed.
I got off parole and I
wanted to move up north
to be with a friend of mine
and I gave two weeks notice
and moved up there and relapsed up north.
And this was part of that still.
I went from there to
San Diego to a program
to try to quit and that didn't work
and I was on my way back to Santa Barbara,
I had a 40 minute layover here in L.A.
and I never got back on the bus.
That's how I got stuck down here.
- [Interviewer] And where
are you staying now?
On the street?
- On the street.
- [Interviewer] Do you have a tent or?
- I have a tent.
They're trying to get me housing.
Sometimes I'm hard to reach
because they steal my
phones left and right,
you can't keep nothing.
So we're back on that again,
so I just got in contact with everybody
and they're like "damn Cynthia,
you missed like six
referrals to go somewhere".
So hopefully Tuesday I have an appointment
we'll see what happens.
- [Interviewer] Good luck.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then
tell me about your childhood,
you had one parent, both parents?
- I had both parents until I was 10
and my dad was an alcoholic.
They got divorced.
She remarried.
That's how I ended up in L.A.
and my dad continued on and he went
and he finally got clean and sober.
He went to AA and so he was
19 years clean and sober
when he died.
So I know AA like the back of my hand,
I know when I'm pulling
the wool over my eyes.
You know, I can't fool myself
but I still go through the motions.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have children of your own?
- I have three, I didn't raise them.
I wasn't capable of doing that.
Drugs just had me.
- [Interviewer] So are
they in foster care?
- [Cynthia] My aunt raised
my two youngest girls
and my old man, my boyfriend's
mother raised my son.
- [Interviewer] Do you
ever talk to your kids?
- [Cynthia] No, hardly ever.
I think my son's in prison.
My daughters are, they're just saying
how they're sick of it.
Cause I'm on and off on and off.
There was a time I was
clean for like three years.
My grandfather was dying of cancer
and he asked me if I could
help him, take care of him,
and so I cleaned up, got on
methadone and took care of him.
And during that period
of time I saw my girls
and on a regular basis and I
was molested by my grandfather.
And so I always talked
to my kids about that.
- [Interviewer] What age were you?
- I don't even know when it started.
But I think it started awful young.
Anyway, I was about nine
and so I used to always
talk to my girls about that.
And I went to visit them one time
and my oldest daughter told me
that her uncle was touching them.
And so I didn't know what to do.
I called the police.
I had investigation, whatever
and so now I'm the bad guy
and my uncle got eight
months work furlough.
So he really didn't do no jail time.
None of my kids, nobody
talks to me anymore
cause I called the cops.
I didn't know what else to do.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, well
you did the right thing.
What would you say to your kids right now?
- I would just want them to know
that I didn't purposely
choose drugs over them.
You know, I can't explain it
but it's just an overwhelming
obsession to use.
And once I got started, I couldn't stop.
I didn't know any better.
It's really hard, you can't explain it
unless you go through it, you know.
It's just fucked up my whole life.
You know, my family had
family businesses and all that
and I wasn't a part of it
because I was out using.
- [Interviewer] What do
you do for money now?
- Whatever I can, I recycle, prostitution,
whatever I can do.
- [Interviewer] That's
dangerous sometimes.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any crazy experiences?
- A lot.
A lot, mostly up in the
state of Washington.
I don't know why up there,
but up there was really bad.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about what's happened?
- You know, pull knives, guns.
I've just somehow managed
to get away every time.
I just knew how to act a certain way
and distract them, just to pop the door
and get out of the car, you know?
- [Interviewer] Well
Cynthia, thank you for that,
I appreciate your time,
good luck out there.
- Okay.